[Musique]
info ou intox avec anthony st léger
anthony bonsoir on va revenir avec vous
sur ces convois de la liberté qui ont
convergé vers paris samedi dernier
depuis de nombreuses vidéos de violences
commises par des policiers ont été
partagés sur les réseaux sociaux
effectivement voici un premier exemple
cette vidéo où on voit un crs qui frappe
avec sa matraque le visage d'un gilet
jaune on a souvent entendu un cette
analogie entre le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et des convois de la liberté ces
derniers temps vidéo qui cumule plus de
cinquante trois mille milles vue elle
provient de ce tweet qui nous dit avec
ce hashtag manif 12 février la police
est une violence incroyable alors c'est
vrai la vidéo est violente mais elle
n'est pas de wii du week-end dernier
plusieurs éléments peuvent mettre la
puce à l'oreille alors il ya bien sûr
l'absence de masques on est quand même
en pleine crise sanitaire même si le
port du masque ce n'est pas forcément
obligatoire dans les rues la tenue aussi
des personnes on est quand même en hiver
ce n'est pas forcément des tenues
adaptées à la saison mais c'est surtout
à la recherche d' image inversée qui va
nous aider à en savoir plus elle nous
renvoie cette recherche à des articles
notamment celui ci de nos confrères de
france info publié le 1er avril 2019
rien à voir donc avec ce week end
pourquoi parce que cette scène elle a
bien eu lieu en 2019 le 30 mars
précisément son état un rassemblement
des gilets jaunes à besançon dans l'est
de l'hexagone et on trouve plusieurs
articles qui évoque aussi la
condamnation lorsque l'on fait une
recherche avec des mots-clés sur google
2019 besançon et gilet jaune la
condamnation du crs en question
condamnation qui a eu lieu pour
agression il ya quatre jours alors autre
vidéo de violence anthony l'est là aussi
il s'agit d'une intox oui ces images
elles ont été à publier regardé dimanche
donc le lendemain de la manifestation
un homme est projeté à terre par
plusieurs policiers l'un d'eux vous
voyez lui assène gratuitement il faut
dire un coup de pied en pleine tête
cette vidéo elle a été vue plus de 80
mille fois elle provient de ce compte
twitter qui nous dit petit coup de pied
en toute discrétion hashtag tout va bien
là aussi bien sur les images sont
violentes mais elle ne date pas de
samedi en l'occurrence n'est pas google
qui va nous aider mais un autre outil
luu thi ty nay qui va être efficace dans
ce cas précis qui va nous permettre de
retrouver l'origine de la vidéo en
l'occurrence un blog hébergé par
mediapart son titre à l'open beauvau du
nom du ministère de l'intérieur
évidemment est un look place beauvau ça
donnera lieu d'ailleurs un roman et un
livre par la suite derrière ce travail
il ya le journaliste david dufresne qui
a suivi les cas de répression policière
lors des rassemblements des gilets
jaunes en 2019 l'article nous apprend là
encore que les images remontent à ces
manifestations de gilet jaune en 2019
l'acte 15 en l'occurrence un
rassemblement à paris le 23 février et
des recherches complémentaires nous
amène à d'autres articles où on apprend
que l'un des policiers présents a été
condamné pour ces faits d'agressions
précisément en novembre 2020 et alors le
succès de ces un fox s'explique par le
contexte des violences commises par les
policiers qui sont bien réels
effectivement on est à deux mois de la
présidentielle aussi ça aide ses enfants
que cette somme est crédible aussi parce
que eh bien il y en a bien eu ouïe des
violences ce week-end des vidéos
authentique qui circulent comme celle ci
par exemple ces images de clément
l'anneau regarder on est sur les champs
elysées cette interpellation musclée
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire elle a été
vue plus de 2 900 86 mille fois presque
987 me l'on frôle tout de même le
million il ya eu aussi cette autre cas
ce policier qui braque avec son arme de
service un automobiliste qui semble-t-il
a refusé de s'arrêter on est à proximité
des champs elysées là encore et pour ce
qu'a d'ailleurs une enquête
administrative interne a été ouverte
alors on sait notamment depuis la crise
des gilets jaunes la police est
régulièrement accusé d'excès dans l'
usage de la force et notamment de
bavures on se souvient je le disais de
la crise des gilets jaunes de ses tirs
de l bd très controversé très contestée
l'onu rappelez-vous à l'époque la haut
commissaire aux droits de l'homme michel
la bachelet avait même interpellé la
france à ce sujet c'est un récurrent
donc ce contexte de violences policières
et ses accusations ceci étant ça ne
signifie pas non plus que les forces de
police elle même ne sont pas victimes de
violences et en l'occurrence selon data
gouv.fr vous voyez ici et grâce à cette
infographie nos confrères du monde il y
a eu 31
1257 faits de violence recensés contre
des forces de l'ordre en 2010 9 27 1659
en 2020 alors des chiffres qui ne sont
pas forcément très récent mais la crise
sanitaire perturbe un petit peu les
estimations en janvier 2021 vous voyez
2288 faits de violence rien que pour un
mois donc merci beaucoup anthony st
léger pour votre chronique qu'on peut
retrouver bien sûr sur notre site
internet
www.francebillet.com nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants après une courte
pause paris direct continue rester avec
nous sur france 24
[Musique]